(upbeat electronic music)
- Well, welcome to another
episode of the "Addy Hour."
Today it's my immense pleasure to be able
to welcome Dr. Michael Eric
Dyson to the "Addy Hour"
for a conversation about race,
community, and mental health.
This is someone who obviously
needs no introduction
but I'm gonna go ahead and
give a brief one anyway.
(Michael laughs)
Dr. Dyson is the Centennial
Chair at Vanderbilt University
and also a University
Distinguished Professor
of African American and Diaspora Studies
in the Colleges of Arts and Sciences
and a University Distinguished Professor
of Ethics and Society
in the Divinity School.
He's someone who also
is a "New York Times"
contributing opinion writer,
also contributing editor at "New Republic"
and ESPN's "The Undefeated,"
has written numerous books,
has another book coming out very soon,
which we'll probably talk
about on this podcast as well,
and he's someone who has won
lots of prestigious awards
including an American Book
Award, two NAACP Image Awards,
and "Ebony" has also cited him as one
of the 100 most influential
African Americans
and one of the 150 most
powerful blacks in the nation.
So someone who continues to
contribute to public discourse
and public debate on
places like "The Late Show"
with Stephen Colbert, "Real
Time with Bill Maher,"
"Good Morning America," "The Today Show,"
"All Things Considered," "Tavis Smiley,"
"Def Poetry Jam," the list goes on and on.
But all that to say is
that I'm very grateful
that he's taken time out
of his busy schedule.
Dr. Dyson, I really
appreciate you being here
on the "Addy Hour" podcast and welcome.
- Thank you, sir.
It's always great to be with
a distinguished intellectual
and, you know, influencer like yourself.
So thanks for having me on.
- Oh, of course, and I
appreciate those kind words.
I'm really excited
about this conversation.
So again, you know, just with the,
all the impact that you have in your place
as such a distinguished
scholar and cultural critic,
a Baptist preacher, activist, influencer,
a lot of the topics that you touch on
are really near and dear
to the conversations
that we have on this podcast as well,
especially as we think about
how aspects of race, racism,
social justice, and
equity impact and interact
with mental health in this country.
So I just wanted to start out, you know,
my listeners know I like to just check in
and see how people are doing,
so in the midst of everything
that's going on with the
ongoing pandemic, with COVID,
with the ongoing systemic
racial injustices,
even as we are preparing
for the start of the trial
for Ahmaud Arbery, the murder trial,
just wanted to ask how you're
doing in this current moment
in general with everything going on.
- Well, thanks for asking.
Yeah, it is a bit much for
all of us to deal with,
with COVID, with the global pandemic,
with the racial reckoning
that we're undergoing still,
the trial of Ahmaud Arbery,
and I write about him in my book,
"Long Time Coming: Reckoning
with Race in America."
So it's a lot for us as a
community but I'm holding up,
holding up the bloodstained
banner of truth
and commitment to the faith
that my ancestors have passed on to me,
that my role models have given to me.
So I'm in good shape
and glad to be here with you this morning.
- Excellent. Well, I appreciate that.
And just the importance of the path
that's been blazed before
us from the ancestors.
I appreciate you mentioning that as well.
The other thing I wanted to ask, you know,
I heard one of your recent interviews
on "The Breakfast Club" when
you were just talking about,
you know, coming up and
not necessarily thinking
about self-care per se in
how you went about things,
but, you know, just thinking
about who you are as a person,
all the conversations that
you're continually involved in,
a lot of heavy topics, how
do you manage all of that
in the midst of just trying to think
about your own emotional wellness
and care in the midst of that?
- Yes, sir, well, I credit
the younger generation
with giving us, your generation
and even those younger,
with forcing us to confront this.
You know, we avoided it.
We were traumatized, re-traumatized,
felt that we had to go on regardless,
and I think there's something
to be said for that mindset,
but there's also something
to be said for reckoning
with your own internal clock,
your rhythm, your cadence,
your flow, your mental health,
your stability, your outlook,
your anxiety meter,
your depression measure,
because we're all bombarded
relentlessly and constantly
from both external stimuli and forces
and internal realities, that
we confront perceptions,
thoughts, emotions, memories
that haunt us, that trigger us.
So it is extremely necessary
to do that kind of inventory.
You know, I like sports events, going out
and looking at basketball and
football and watching movies.
(laughs) So those are some of
the things that keep me going,
keep me refreshed and the like,
and listening to music and so on,
going to a concert and so on.
Those kinds of things
are extremely important,
trying to get in an exercise
regimen, get in better shape,
you know, 'cause you gotta
be here in order to be here.
- Yeah, yeah, that's true.
- And
so I think the younger
generation has reminded us
of the politics of self-care
and the necessity of engaging it
without the kind of guilt
that older people did,
without lapsing into some
of the extremes of self-care
'cause if self-care comes
at the expense of other care
or myopic narcissistic self-preoccupation
at the expense of commitment
to the larger society.
Was it good for Martin Luther
King Jr. to do all he did?
If he was really
concerned about self-care,
would he have marched on some days?
No.
Would he have spoken
on some other days? No.
So you got to balance out, you know,
a commitment to a higher
purpose and a greater goal
with also the recognition
that you've got to be here
and in good space and spirits and body
and in health and mind in order
to render the best service possible.
- Yeah, that's so good,
and it sounds like you have
so many of those pieces
just baked in to what
you do on a daily basis.
I think it's really keeping you,
you touched on the
generational difference too
and I even see that myself, you know,
even with younger trainees,
they're coming up,
it seems like they're so invested
in so many different things,
which I felt like in some
ways I kind of waited
till I got to a certain level of stature
before I really jumped into
some of those passions,
even though those passions were there.
How was that process for
you in terms of, you know,
developing your passions
and pursuing them?
How did that come about and
how'd you get to this place
in your career being so involved
in so many different spheres of influence?
- Well, as they say in basketball,
I took what the defense gave me.
(both laughing)
So it's what opportunities
and obstacles presented themselves,
some doors opening, other doors closing,
and some windows being lifted
and some being nailed shut.
It doesn't mean that I
have a fatalistic outlook
and perspective that suggests
that if it's difficult,
therefore it's not for
me, that's not the case,
but if you keep banging
your head against the window
and knocking against the
door and it ain't open
and then consider opening another door,
considering that door ain't for you,
considering that God might
be looking out for you,
what you asking for ain't
what you need to have
without being paternalistic
or masking human authoritarianism
with an appeal to, you
know, God's Providence.
But at the end of the day,
you got to have a sense of connection
and spiritual attunement so
that you are constantly praying
for the best path, looking
for the best opportunity,
trying to create the
next level of investment
and the return on that investment
and what your spiritual
growth and your career growth
and your professional growth
and your vocational growth will be.
So for me, it's been a measure
of trying to match my goals and my gifts.
What goals are dictated by my gifts?
Now, you might want to
be a basketball player.
There are some who are my
height, maybe 5'10", you know,
maybe I-
- There's some good examples.
- What was that? (laughs)
- There's some good examples
at your height.
but the fact that they're relatively few,
which suggests that that ain't, you know,
the likelihood as
opposed to a person 6'5",
6'10", and so on.
So, or what are your skills
and what are your intuitions
generated as a result of?
And so when I look at what
my intuitional base is,
it's premised on an intellectual
engagement with the world,
an analysis of things as they are,
a kind of spiritual connection to them
as an ordained minister,
as an intellectual,
as a professor, you know,
I develop those talents.
So thinking and reflecting and writing
and engaging the world.
And as a result of that, doors opened.
Opportunities presented themselves.
And I began to reinforce the
value of my self-perception
and linking my goals and my gifts.
And I think if more of us
would link our goals and gifts,
we would understand, you know,
how it is that what God has
placed in us can be elicited,
can be evoked, can be brought out
as a result of whatever circumstances,
opportunities, or obstacles
present themselves
that, you know, encourage us, coerce us
to deal with what's around us.
So, you know, my pastor
coming into my church
when I was 12 years old,
me entering a oratorical
contest when I was 11 years old,
being asked to speak parts in church
when I was younger than that,
my fifth grade teacher, Mrs. James,
teaching us about black history
when it wasn't popular in 1968-
- Wow, that's saying something.
- And winning a blue ribbon
for reciting the poetry
of Paul Laurence Dunbar
and on and on and on.
So my gifts matched, you know,
and dictated to a degree my goals.
If this is my skillset, if
these are my gifts and talents,
what do I use them to realize
and what ambitions do I nurture
in my own heart and mind
in order to find that relationship
between my gifts and my goals
and that allow me to
live a satisfying life?
So that's how I've
tried to play it so far.
- Yeah. That's really powerful.
And the fact that you remember
your fifth grade teacher's
name, that's saying something.
- Oh man, she was extremely important,
life-changing, you know?
My mother told me later that
many of the black parents,
'cause I'm in a segregated school
even though I'm living
up north in Detroit,
we had a white principal,
Mrs. Christianson, I remember,
but we had black teachers and black staff
and everything else was
black in that school,
including the students.
And my mother said they
went to Mrs. Christianson
and complained to her,
some of the black parents,
about the black fifth
grade teacher, Mrs. James.
What are they going to do
with this black history stuff?
This is not part of the curriculum.
Well, I'll tell you, I'm a
PhD from Princeton University
and I've written 25 books
and I write about politics
and race and culture and religion
and all the stuff that she taught us then.
So Mrs. James, your efforts paid off.
- Wow, yeah. Such a
legacy and such an impact.
I love how you put those two together
when you're following your,
putting your goals and
your passions together.
You know, I'm just thinking, you know,
in terms of some of our listeners
and just things I've heard from
people who might say, well,
I have these goals and these passions,
but I don't have any opportunities
to actually carry those things out
or are running into obstacles
even as you talked about trying
to have that discernment,
about knowing when to
push through something
if there's resistance, but
also knowing when to shift.
So how have you done that in your life
when those obstacles have come up
and how would you give advice
to others who may be listening
who are saying, well, I have
these passions and goals,
but I just can't find a lane or an avenue
to really move that stuff forward.
- Well, that's part of the deal, right?
That's part of the package.
If you don't have a lane, if
you don't have an opportunity
after so many tries,
after so many attempts,
and there's no measure,
no metric that is scientifically rooted.
You don't know if it's 10
years or 10 days, you know?
It's depending upon what your spirit is,
what your outlook is,
how much cash you got,
what you need to do in the meantime,
how many kids you got,
who you got to raise,
what parents, you need to
address their situation.
So all of these existential
measures are indices,
are marks, are metrics that we deploy
to determine how much stick-to-it-iveness
we should display in a particular pursuit.
You know, some people, you know,
Toni Morrison wasn't a professional writer
till she was what, 39 years old.
Imagine had she given up,
we would have missed arguably
the greatest American writer
of her generation, the
greatest black writer ever.
And we would have missed out on "Sula"
or we would've missed out on Milkman Dead.
We would've missed out on, you know,
"Beloved" and so on and
so forth and, you know,
we would have missed out on her genius.
So thank God she was persistent,
but she had a job in the meantime.
She was an editor at Random House.
She was editing Angela Davis's work.
She was working with Toni Cade Bambara.
So she was nurturing talent
as she was nurturing her own.
Her job was one thing,
her vocation another,
her vision yet another.
If you can find a space, as
I tell my sons and daughter,
find something you would do
if nobody paid you a dime
and then figure out a way
to make money doing it
so you can support yourself,
so you can support your dream.
So there's no exact
scientific calibration.
There's no exact scientific
measure or metric
or meter or goal determiner.
It's what you're made of and
it's what you're looking at
and it's how much you're
able to sustain yourself
in the midst of that and how
tenacious you are willing to be
and persistent in the face of opposition,
in the face of opposition.
So, you know, and in my case,
you know, I wanted to
write, I wanted to think,
I thought I was gonna be a minister,
I am a minister who was
a pastor, but I went,
I pastored three different churches,
got kicked out of the third one
'cause I was trying to ordain three women
as deacons back in '83,
and that door closed on me.
Now I'm still committed to
gender justice in the church
but maybe the pastor, it
wasn't the path for me.
And so when that door
closed rather precipitously,
you know, I began to focus
on becoming a scholar
and using my gifts that way
and maybe my ministry was in the classroom
and not in the pulpit alone or primarily.
And so you get signals
and hints and indications,
again, how do you know
which one is for you or not?
It's an experimentation.
It's a trial and error.
Sometimes trial and terror
because the lack of
fulfillment can terrorize you,
can tantalize you, can traumatize you.
So you got to figure it out.
You know, what are your resources?
What are your internal senses of things?
What are your intuitions
about what you're doing
and how much more you can take?
You know, we say God doesn't put anything
on you that you can't take,
any more on your plate
than you can consume
or any more weight on your
shoulders than you can bear.
Sometimes that's a tough, tough way to go.
But having said that, in my case,
testing, as the Bible
says, test the spirits,
testing out what my gifts and goals were
as I reshaped my goals
premised upon my gifts
or the particular moment
in which I was able
to realize those goals and ambitions,
'cause I had my goals and I had my gifts
but I didn't have, as you said,
the opportunity to realize them.
What do I do in the meantime?
How do I realize it?
How do I recognize
there's more than one way
to get to a particular goal?
If you live in New York
and you're trying to get to
Broadway, there are many ways,
many more streets and avenues
to get there, to that street.
So you've got to look at
alternative routes and the like.
So when you put all that together,
it gives you a sense of how
much you're willing to invest,
how long you're willing to invest it,
how much you're capable
of sustaining yourself
in the midst of that, and
everything ain't for everybody.
Every route is not for everybody else.
Your route is unique and
different than my route, so,
but if we have the same goal
of realizing our ambitions
and the willingness to stick to it,
sometimes that determines
even more than talent,
just the ability to sit
your butt in the seat
and keep writing, keep
thinking, keep talking,
keep doing what you do, just
outlasting everybody else
until your opportunity comes.
So you've got to be moved by the measure
and the moment of the spirit within,
the sense of within, the
intuition from within,
and the downright dogged determination
to do what you gotta do until
you can reach your goals.
I mean, all of that is
a measure of what to do
and there's no scientific
way to tell anybody to do it.
- Mm-hm, and I definitely appreciate that
even as a scientist, 'cause as you said,
that's just not the way it flows,
and just that persistence in the passion
regardless of the doors closing
even as you were sharing
aspects of your story as well.
But you touched a little bit
about the generational differences,
some of the positive
generational differences
in terms of really
incorporating that self-care
and having a balance in that way too.
From your lens and your perspective,
have you also seen any
generational differences
in terms of expectation?
'Cause you touched on that.
You know, some of these things
didn't happen in a minute.
They may have taken 10 months, 10 years.
And how do you keep that passion
while the prize isn't there?
Not to break it down
too much generationally,
but I'm just curious from your, you know,
from what you've seen over the years.
- Yeah, no, I think there
are generational differences.
Some of us exaggerate them
because genre may be more
important than generation,
by which I mean if you were a
hustler a hundred years ago,
you might be a hustler today.
If you were tenacious a hundred years ago,
you might be tenacious today.
A certain kind of personality
that bucked the system,
you could have been Nat Turner then,
you could be Stacey Abrams now.
So the genre, the measure,
the spirit, the approach,
the style of difference could
persist over space and time.
On the other hand, you could
be Frederick Douglas then,
you could be Malcolm X now, and so on.
You could be Harriet Tubman then.
You can be Sherrilyn Ifill now.
Now, having said that,
I think there are
differences of generation
in terms of expectation,
'cause look at the load,
the burden that's put on this generation.
Can you imagine if we,
I mean, I didn't have Facebook coming up.
I had to face the book and read it.
(both laughing)
The only Facebook, face
that book, boy, and read it.
You know, I didn't have Twitter.
I was a-twitter. I was
excited about stuff.
You know, swipe left,
swipe right. (laughs)
You know, what's that thing
they call when you do,
the dating service when you're
swiping and stuff, Tinder.
Yeah, we had to be tender in our emotions
toward the people we loved,
but we ain't had no Tinder
to figure out-
- You're more on top of this
than I am, for God's sake. (laughs)
- Yeah, who to date.
I mean, social media is a game changer
and in many ways it's
been an extraordinary,
the internet has been extraordinary.
Stuff it took you, like, I
had to go to the lie-bury
to figure out where the lies were buried
and dig them up.
- Oh, for goodness. (laughs)
- Coming to books, you
had to go to the library,
the periodical readers, catalog, all that,
you have to go to the, man, you know,
to find out what article
was published in what year.
Man, that was shoe
leather. That was pavement.
That was physical geography and archeology
of knowledge in books,
which I love, I still do,
smelling them, going to bookstores
and libraries where you could just browse.
I wasn't even looking for
that book and it popped up,
Professor Addy and what is going on
and I didn't even know about
that and that's amazing.
Now you can browse even more reams
of gigs of data on the internet.
Stuff that used to take
us, you know, weeks,
you can now have at your fingertips
and archives of knowledge
and digitized books
and libraries, it's phenomenal.
On the other hand, man, there's,
the expectation is out of order.
You know, you're gonna
be immediately successful
and if you're not, we're
going to note it on Twitter.
You didn't do well and your
book didn't sell as much
and your work doesn't pay
off as quickly as others
'cause now you're measuring
not just the person
in your own neighborhood
or in your own classroom,
you're measuring yourself
against all of the people
on Twitter, all of the people on Facebook,
all of the people on Instagram
and you're looking at what they're doing
and you're figuring you ain't
got what they got and so on.
Now, it's not that keeping up
with the Joneses didn't prevail before,
but if you didn't have the Instagram
to see somebody posting
up, archiving their lives
in a way that ain't really the truth,
got filters on there, that ain't
really what they look like,
they got cellulite or cellu-heavy,
whatever they selling you anyway.
So the point is all this stuff
now, filters and, you know,
stories and archiving your life
in a way that's not organic necessarily,
I'm not crapping on it,
it's another outlet,
but dadgum, there are some
lethal deleterious consequences
to that as well.
And also in terms of expectations,
people gonna be perfect and
live a certain kind of way.
You sitting up on the
internet judging people,
you sitting up on Twitter
administering cancel culture,
I know it ain't popular to talk about it.
People say, oh, cancel
culture doesn't exist.
That's the right wing phenomenon.
They don't want to be held accountable.
That's true for many people
who are conservative,
or, not the same thing,
people who are racist
or sexist or transphobic
or homophobic and all that,
they just don't want to be called out.
So I get that.
On the other hand,
there is something about
the self-righteousness
that you judge in other people
that you can't make a mistake
or if you make a mistake,
you can't overcome it
and acknowledge you did it.
No, you're canceled. You're done.
That's ludicrous. That's crazy.
- No room for growth.
- There is no room for growth
because you can't admit you messed up
and now nobody can admit
that they made an error
'cause if you admit you made an error,
then you can't say nothing
and you can't talk about it
and you can't open yourself up to it.
There's no continuum. There's
no spectrum to be had here.
There's no difference.
You know, and some of
these feminists who are,
you know, talking about certain things,
be treating women worse than anybody else.
Some of these anti-racists
hate black people more
than anybody else.
So I'm saying like, dogs, slow down
with that kind of judgment
'cause I've seen you
from behind the scenes.
I know the kind of
funky stuff you're doing
and, okay, you can grow, you can develop,
you can have an organic
relationship with truth
and, you know, evolution
of mind and so on.
And, you know, all of us need the space
to admit we messed up and
grow, but nobody can do it.
Nobody can say they messed up now.
Nobody can acknowledge that
they have made a mistake
because to acknowledge that mistake
is to immediately be judged
and to be done away with
and to have the swift, you
know, digital lynch mob descend
upon, you know, vulnerable people,
and we're all vulnerable
people, so we can never mess up.
We can never 'fess up and then dress up
and move on to the next situation.
And I'm, you know, that
to me is destructive,
it's painful, and it's
problematic to the nth degree.
- Yeah, yeah. Totally agree with that.
And I'm curious what you think
on how we actually cultivate that
because that's such an important piece.
I mean, I was saying
there's no room for growth.
We aren't perfect people.
If we don't have room to grow,
we're not gonna get through the challenges
and get to a place of healing,
and then even as I think about that
and tie that back into mental health,
not to say that mental
health challenges are an area
where people have messed up,
but it's an area of struggle.
And so I think that same kind of feeling
comes into the mental health piece too
where people are struggling,
there's no room to say I'm struggling
because that looks like imperfection.
So how do we actually cultivate that
and get to a healthier place
where we can all actually grow
and heal and move forward
and get off of this facade
as it were of having that-
- Yeah, no, it's a great point.
I mean, stop lying to yourself
and admit to yourself you
messed up, but you can't do it
'cause if I admit to myself I messed up,
then I got imposter syndrome
and I don't think I belong there.
And then mentally look
at what you're doing.
The mendacity, the lies,
the thick coat of lies.
You're talking about self-help
or you're talking about,
you know, self-care,
how are you gonna care about yourself
if you can't tell yourself the truth?
But you can't tell yourself the truth
because if you tell yourself the truth
and you have to balance some
of the stuff that's going on,
then you'd have to tell
others that same truth
and you'd have to admit
that you ain't as perfect
as it appears that you are.
And again, the social structure
then prevents individual consciousness,
the individuation that is a
measure of psychological health,
the ability to individuate,
to establish a basis of
individual ego-driven
in the best sense of that word recognition
and self-identification with those goals
and aspirations nurtured in you
that produce a healthy outcome,
a healthy ego, a healthy sense of self,
whether you're dealing
with analytical psychology
of Karl Gustav Jung, or, you know,
the psychoanalytic framework of Freud
or the indirect approach of Rogers,
or, you know, the best of
black psychological therapy
that joins a consciousness
of anti-blackness
to the kind of self-hatred
that might be uncritically
or unconsciously internalized, whatever.
At the end of the day, if
you can't acknowledge that,
if you can't fess up and
say dadgum it, I messed up,
or I'm not perfect and I need help,
it's a contradictory message.
On the one hand, self-care is about
I'm not well enough today.
I'm Naomi Osaka, I can't follow through,
I'm Simone Biles, I can't
follow through, and so on,
and then if you admit
that, and then if you say,
but then, you know, part
of the blame could be
that I'm not ready, I didn't prepare,
I'm psychologically
not ready for the world
that is hurting me,
oh, what, what's wrong?
So, you know, it's tough out
here to be able to do that.
So you've got to have
a world, create scenes,
cosmoses, you know, worldviews,
intimate connections, communities,
gatherings, organizations,
where you're able to share
that knowledge, be safe,
a safe place where you can tell the truth
and not be immediately judged.
And one person's safe space
is another person's vulnerability.
And even if people insist
on their having safe spaces,
they're developing those at
the expense of forcing others
to bow down before their narrow conception
of what is appropriate and
good and healthy and uplifting.
So we got to be honest about this stuff
and stop holding each other
to unreasonable standards
and unrighteous attempts to assault people
out of self-righteousness.
Now, yes, there's a way
in which you can hold
each other accountable
even as we recognize our faults and flaws.
it doesn't mean that
therefore anything goes
and as long as I say I messed up
that I don't have to be accountable.
Yes, we all have to be held accountable.
There are things that I've done
of which I am enormously ashamed,
and I can say that openly.
But man, I can't really
get too specific about it
'cause if I get too specific,
then others, you know,
began to chime in and yap and hate on you
while they're not admitting
the stuff that they did.
You know, some sins are
more visible than others.
Some flaws are more evident than others.
Others are emotional sins or
internal psychological sins
that we commit against self or others.
Bad words, bad thoughts,
accompanying bad deeds.
So, you know, we got
to be extremely careful
and cautious about the
judgmentalism and the harshness
that goes in the name
of politically correct
or even woke ideology about
holding people to account.
If Martin Luther King Jr. could
forgive white supremacists
and racists and people who
were killing black people,
then we got to show some
more love to each other
than we showed to the white people
who tried to murder us back in the day
and some who are doing it today.
- Yeah, wow, there's a lot
there, so much that's important
and things that I think that
we can really pull apart.
One piece I wanted to
ask a little bit more
and kind of dig deep in is this idea
of individual versus community,
'cause you talked about, you know,
how we haven't paid attention to that
in terms of our self-care, but I'm curious
just even in terms of the
historical context of that
in this country and what
the, you know, such the,
the emphasis on the community
suffering that was happening
and kind of the importance
of resilience is a word
that gets thrown around
for good or for bad,
and, I mean, we could
dig into that as well,
but how do we balance those two?
Because in one sense, it
seems that the individual,
individualism was squelched in order
so that we could thrive as a community.
At the same time, that could happen
at the expense of the individual.
So how do we balance that
in our current moment?
Because there are even ways
that that happens today,
even thinking about the
mental health aspect,
so thinking about some of the work
that David Williams has done at Harvard,
just showing the negative
mental health impacts
in black and brown communities in states
where individuals have been
killed at the hands of police,
unarmed individuals,
and the effect that has
on the community and on the individual.
So I guess I'm trying to, you know,
how do we tease those pieces apart?
Because they're both important
but there's consequences
of leaning too heavily
on one side or the other.
- Yeah, no doubt.
I mean, David Williams,
Joy DeGruy, you know,
when you think about
the post slave syndrome,
post-slave traumatic syndrome,
where she speaks about the
trauma we endure collectively
as an enslaved people.
So, and brother Williams.
So yeah, the psychological consequence,
but they've also done
psychological studies of hope,
that people who hope
unrealistically suffer just as much.
Like, ooh, so it's deep now.
You get too much unrealistic
hope, you jacked up.
You're too pessimistic, you jacked up.
You're too nihilistic, you jacked up.
Dadgum, what's a brother to
do? What's a sister to do?
So the thing is, is that, yeah,
there are community traumas,
communities that are traumatized.
When we see black people who are subject
to the vicious, you know,
assault of a dominant
white supremacist society,
that traumatizes all of us
and our individuality is wiped away.
The irony is the struggle
of the collective
is for the individual to be acknowledged.
Don't treat us like that dadgum
parts of the same community
only in terms of your stereotype.
All black people are lazy.
All black people, you know,
are unfaithful to the task at hand, right?
All black people are,
and fill in the blanks.
Everything you say about black people
is true about everybody, every group,
but you begin to stereotype
and rigorously, or, you
know, don't apply rigor
to your deconstruction of those practices,
dispositions, habits, and inclinations
of black people to
behave in a certain way.
And that they're not just black,
everybody does that, right?
Every community that is poor will engage
in criminal activity,
every community whose back
is against the wall, right?
Poles, Jews, Italians,
you know, in this country
who were in the shadow and the ghetto
before African people were in America.
At the same time, the unique
condition of being enslaved
in this country and then being, you know,
then having the force and power
of the state turned against
us and denying our humanity,
that has to be acknowledged too,
and the psychological
consequences of that.
So yes, there's a
psychological consequence
to being treated as a group,
all black people, and fill in the blanks,
all black people, fill in the blanks,
all black people, fill in
the blanks, the stereotypes,
the narrow conceptions, and a stereotype
is a lazy person's way of
dealing with the other.
Some of it, some small
part of it could be true,
but the vast majority of the
data rests upon a refusal
to acknowledge the person before me
and to put the group before,
all Jews, all Poles, all
Italians, all Lithuanians,
and all Polish and blah, blah, blah,
you know, do X, Y, and Z,
as opposed to dealing with
the individual person,
Jewish, Italian, Polish, you know,
Korean, before me, while at the same time,
acknowledging that there are group traits
that are developed as a result
of having imposed upon those
groups certain restrictions
so that a group
consciousness is developed.
But you mad at us,
why all you black people got
to come together as a group?
Why can't you be treated as an individual?
That's when they want.
They don't want to deal
with the racism question,
the structural characteristics of racism.
Well, be treated as an individual.
But you don't treat us as individuals.
You continually treat us as
members of a particular group
that you stereotype or
you're prejudiced against.
So you go up to a black
person you don't even know
and hate them because they are black.
That ain't got nothing to
do with the individual data,
experience, engagement with that person.
You're treating us as a collective.
So it's collective when it's convenient.
It's individual when it's
to the delight or benefit
of that particular person
or community assessing us.
So yeah, you got the individual
stuff on the one hand
where we're treated as individuals,
exceptions from the
group, that's problematic.
You're better than,
Dr. Addy, you're better
than most of the other people
that I've met of your color
and you got a better
character and you're more,
you're hard-working and go and praise you
at the expense of your group
through the means of a stereotype
that dishonors the group
and therefore exaggerates
or distorts the individual.
So yeah, that stuff is tough, no doubt,
and there are issues on both sides
as a collective, as an individual.
And we've got to confront those.
We've got to acknowledge
our group solidarity
and we've got to acknowledge our quest
for individual expression
so that we don't impose those
restraints on each other.
You know, you ain't really
black 'cause you scuba dive.
black 'cause you're trans.
No, you ain't really
black 'cause you're queer.
No, you ain't really black
'cause you're Afrofuturist.
You ain't really black because
you like country music.
you only listen to Beethoven
and not Busta Rhymes and on and on and on.
So we impose these constraints,
impose these narrow limits
on ourselves as well.
Now, that's not to say
that those who operate
within our communities who are hurting
and harming black people, who self-hate,
and as a result of that,
other-hate, that's real too.
But everybody who's not part
of the group in the main
is not a self-hater and
doesn't want to undermine
the capacity of black people
to move forward as a community.
They want to argue for some oxygen,
to breathe the air that they
feel most comfortable inhaling.
So it's a constant battle.
It's a constant pivoting between,
toggling between the
collective and the individual,
but the corrosive consequences of both,
of seeing our black people traumatized
and that regardless of our, you know,
our economic status or our racial beliefs
or our religious orientation
or our sexual orientation,
on the one hand, then there's
the stuff we do to each other
to impose narrow constraints
and judgments on each other
and it's what we have to
put up with in a society
that wants to touch our hair,
that wants to believe that
microaggressions are harmless,
the Karens of the world,
to dictate where we can eat
and not eat, sell water
and not sell water,
lemonade, not lemonade,
barbecue, not barbecue,
go into, you know, a coffee shop
and be treated as a thug and the like,
or at a university and
be seen as out of place.
So all of that stuff
we're constantly trying
to negotiate between, and
it's even more havoc wreaked
when we impose those
narrow vicious beliefs
on each other as well.
- Yeah, yeah, that's so well said
because of all the
tensions between the two,
as you mentioned, you know, I'm curious
from your perspective as a sociologist
and just all the other
hats that you wear too,
'cause you talked about,
you know, all the things,
all the risks of being a
black person in this country,
as you've just gone through,
and I know you mentioned that
in your convocation address
at Meharry Medical College as well.
How do you see that impacting
our mental health in general
and just our outlook in the world
and how do we actually
try and move through that,
you know, not necessarily
maybe from a mental health lens
or psychiatric or psychological lens,
but from your perspective
as a sociologist, like,
what are healthy ways
that we can actually,
one, how does it impact us
and what are healthy ways
we can move through that to still thrive
and not have this false sense
of hope that you talked about?
- Yeah, well, you know, you
want to have as clear a concept
of your capacities as possible
so that you can have
a realistic assessment
of your likely trajectory of success
and achievement in the world.
You got to figure out ways to
have a realistic assessment
of self in regard to obstacles
that might prevent the
flourishing of that self
and therefore negotiate a world
that is constantly throwing up obstacles
and you're constantly, through resilience,
trying to overcome them,
trying to engage them,
but also use them as grist
for your meal as a story
in your larger narrative
of success or overcoming.
So you gotta be as cunning and as clever
and as crafty as our ancestors, you know,
faking like they liked stuff
when they didn't like it,
you know, yes sir, master,
when they were like, mm-hm,
giving them the bird behind the scenes,
or putting, shall we say,
urination into their water
to make it taste better,
finding everyday forms of resistance,
aborting babies sometimes
from enslavement,
breaking tools and implements,
hey, it don't work,
what you want me to do?
Breaking the legs of animals
so that they couldn't,
you know, be used and
deployed and enslaved to work.
So they were all kind of crafty, cunning,
creative, clever ways
we found to negotiate.
Now, I don't want any
animals to be hurting.
I don't want any tools to
be broken unnecessarily,
but I'm talking about
an approach, a mindset,
a mental health strategy
that says that at all costs,
I must maintain my belief
that God has blessed me,
the universe has blessed me,
if you don't believe in God,
that I am who I am as a
result of the talent I have,
I should be able to recognize that talent
in a goal-oriented society
that throws up impediments
and, you know, things that
prevent my flourishing.
I've got to constantly fight against that.
I got to fight against the self-doubt
that has been implanted in me
not because of an inherent
sense of inferiority,
but by an imposed one
that has been inherited
from a dominant white supremacist logic
that continues to constrain who I am
or a sense of self in the midst of that.
So mental health, you got
to, you know, maintain,
you know, like, look, I'm worthy.
I'm good.
It's all right to acknowledge
my vulnerabilities
and my faults and my flaws,
but also to stand up and to
celebrate my achievements,
the vast region of possibility
that I have barely begun to tap,
that is open to me and I must insist
on realizing that ambition.
That's a mentally healthy thing to do.
You know, the new movie
"King Richard" is coming out
where Richard Williams, the
father of Venus and Serena,
had to fight a bunch of stereotypes.
He's crazy. He's got two daughters.
What does he know?
He has no experience with tennis
and he's in Compton and
the concrete jungle.
What the hell does he know?
Well, enough to produce two of
the greatest tennis players,
one, arguably the greatest
tennis player ever bar gender,
another one, one of the
greatest of all time in Venus.
So yeah, he was crazy like a fox mentally,
spiritually, emotionally,
against the grain,
looking unorthodox, sometimes
we have to be unorthodox.
Sometimes we have to be on the margins.
We can't be in the main, the main stream.
You have to flow in
the way and the cadence
that has been given to you,
the moral ambitions that
have been nurtured in you,
the styles, the measures and means
that are most akin to your flourishing,
that don't hurt or harm others.
So in terms of mental health, yeah.
You know, you got to figure
out ways to affirm self,
to love self, to embrace
self as other selves
creatively engage in the same process,
fighting for opportunities, opening doors,
not feeling that your success is harmed
if another person's success is present,
a lot of things we can do to
reinforce our sense of self.
Go to church, go to
temple, go to synagogue,
read a religious book,
have a set of affirmations,
have goals that are articulated
on refrigerator doors
and on and on and on.
Read, you know, the Bhagavad Gita,
the Holy Quran, the Tao Te Ching,
whatever it is that floats your boat,
Superman, Batman, comic books, you know,
rap lyrics, Lil Wayne, Dr. Dre,
Jay-Z, Lauryn Hill, you know,
whatever it takes to sustain you.
Listen to Anita Baker or Luther Vandross
or whatever it is that uplifts you,
that gives you the confidence and courage
and conviction to move forward
and have a strong self-concept,
a mentally healthy
outlook that keeps at bay
the demons of depression and distress
and anxiety that eat away at the fabric
of your self-confidence in this world.
- Mm, so well said, and
I love all the pieces
that you pulled in 'cause
there's so much of that
that ties into the brain
science and the neuroscience
of what we need moving forward
to even, as you talked about,
the expectation that we have for ourselves
or the importance of community
or the importance of music
and how that really engages, you know,
reward pathways in our
brains that are important
for helping us kind of move through things
on a day-to-day basis.
So it was great hearing that, you know,
that perspective from you as a minister,
a sociologist and professor,
and how that ties in so
strongly to neuroscience
about what it really means for our brains
and helps us to move through
some of these challenges
in a lot of ways as well.
And again, it loops back to
what you mentioned early on,
I think too, about that
balance between the self-care
and then also kind of
moving through things
but not trying to sway one
way or the other, but, I mean,
the way that you kind
of painted that picture
for really having a holistic balance
and really having those pieces
baked in, as you mentioned,
I think, is so powerful.
And I imagine that, you know,
even if it hasn't been
something that you've stated
throughout your long career,
it seems like you have
those pieces in place
to really kind of keep those
pieces in check in a sense
which I think is really-
- Yes sir, no, no, no,
well-stated, eloquent,
more eloquently than I did,
but yes, sir, and those
neuropathways that are developed,
those endorphins that are released,
the cycle chemical, cycle
neurochemical possibilities
that are unleashed.
If it's good for your soul,
it's good for your endorphins.
It's good for the biology.
It's good for the neuro-transmitters
that carry messages of hope
and aspiration and possibility
without being, you know,
narrowly retrofitted as positive
as opposed to deeply rooted in hope,
'cause hope confronts the
negative, confronts the horrible,
confronts the terrorizing,
the traumatizing,
and then gives answer to those pathways
that portend nuclear
explosion in your brain
and redirect them towards
something more powerful
and uplifting and beautiful
and edifying at the same time.
- Oh, totally agreed. Full
circle in a lot of ways.
I know we're running short on time
but I did want to give you a chance
just to talk about your
upcoming book as well
'cause I know that's gonna
be released very soon,
and what should readers expect
from this latest gifting?
- Well, thank you, sir.
"Entertaining Race: Performing
Blackness in America"
is a kind of collection
of stuff I've been doing
for nearly the last 30 years.
Sermons, essays, reviews, film,
you know, interviews with me and others,
commencement speeches, protest speeches,
op-eds, every genre.
I've got a restless
fascination with literacy
and expression and how to articulate ideas
and aspirations that are
not limited to one genre.
And so people will get a chance
to peek into my own spirit,
my mind, my soul, my
desires, my ambitions,
my thoughts, and see me reckoning
and wrestling with them
out loud in public spaces
that allow others to be
challenged, to be championed,
and hopefully to be uplifted
at the same time to do their own thing,
to express themselves in
ways that are appropriate
and uplifting not only to themselves,
but to the communities around them.
- Well, I look forward to reading.
I mean, even the way you
just characterized that,
I love the fact that
it has that wrestling,
the wrestling and the hope together
'cause as we were talking,
that seems, I mean,
that's the key piece so that
we don't get in this facade
of not having to work through things
to get to a place of hope and healing, so.
- Yes, sir. Thank you, my brother.
- Well, I appreciate you
taking the time again
to be on the "Addie Hour"
and this is a conversation
I think a lot of people
are gonna go back to
and probably listen to a few
times to catch all the nuances
and the nuggets that
you dropped throughout.
So really appreciate your time with us
and just for joining this conversation.
- Thanks for having me.
Keep up that extremely important work
of keeping us on the right
path of mental health,
mental wellbeing, emotional security
in the midst of vulnerability.
Thank you so much for the
work you do, my friend.
- Of course. Oh, my pleasure.
Glad to contribute in a meaningful way.
- Thank you, sir.
(upbeat electronic music)